deux explosions se sont produites sur le
site de la snp à bergerac en fin de
matinée bilan cinq blessés légers et une
personne brûlée superficiellement mais
extrêmement choqué tous ont été conduits
à l'hôpital pour des examens j'ai vu que
les pompiers arrivés et puis on m'a dit
qu'il y avait eu une explosion puis
c'est tout c'est une conduite
c'est lors d'une d'un démontage une
conduite qui aurait
duré une double explosion voilà les
explosions se sont produites alors que
les ouvriers travailler au démontage
d'une chaîne qui n'était plus en service
depuis plusieurs mois mais les tuyaux
contenaient des résidus de
nitrocellulose l'incident a été contenue
dans l'atelier et n'a entraîné ni dégâts
matériels ni pollution
[Musique]